now we have 250 7,000 jobs at in the
month of January another strong month
revisions make it even better the
unemployment rate ticked up to five
point seven percent and the big story
here wages jumping the most
month-over-month that we've seen in six
years there's some annual adjustments in
this number but by and large it's a
pretty clean report not much impact from
those annual revisions let me walk you
through a two hundred fifty seven
thousand jobs in the month of January
better than our survey number of 228,000
the revisions to the prior months at a
hundred and forty-seven thousand jobs
November now revised to four hundred and
twenty three thousand jobs that's the
best month we've seen since May of 2010
best private sector month we've seen
since sep tember of 1997 december
revised up to three hundred twenty-nine
thousand three-month average now 336,000
jobs the benchmark revision seasonal
adjustments account for some of that pop
that we saw in the two month revisions
overall for 2014 3.1 million jobs
created the best year we've seen since
1999 let's talk about the household
survey the unemployment rate five point
seven percent up slightly from five
point six percent but the participation
rate takes up as well up 0.2% 260 2.9
both employed and unemployed moving
higher and again this is a pretty clean
number the annual population control
adjustments that are done each January
zero effect on both the unemployment
rate and the participation rate that's
important long-term unemployed 2.8
million essentially unchanged the
underemployment rate moving higher to
11.3 percent from 11.2 percent who was
hiring in January retail at 46,000
construction 39,000 healthcare 38,000
financial activities 26,000
manufacturing 22,000 we lost 10,000 jobs
in the government sector transportation
and warehousing down 9,000 14,000 jobs
lost couriers and messengers mining and
logging of course big interest in the
oil and gas sector mining logging down
3,000 oil and gas down specifically 2000
and the wage store here average hourly
earnings jumping 0.5% month over month
the best single month jump we've seen
since November of 2008 year over
year that number moving higher 2.2% best
since August of 2014 so the bottom line
here Matt we're looking at another solid
jobs number in terms of the non-farm
payroll unemployment ticking up but
perhaps for the right reasons
participation rate increasing and wages
moving higher in a big way bottom line
there's a lot in this report that
perhaps to call into question how
patient Janet Yellen can be going
forward yeah absolutely Peter